so GOP versus ESG why Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis Republicans are fighting
VOC ESG investing okay so woke ESG
investing and there's a lot of this
going on right now
um
why do Republicans have a problem with
ESG the acronym for environmental social
governance principles isn't widely known
outside investment circles but it's fast
becoming a popular GOP talking point in
the run-up to 2024 presidential election
the GOP says the top nation's top money
managers are pushing an ideological
agenda at the expense of financial
returns in violation of their fiduciary
duty in an effort to stop public Pension
funds from using ESG as a consideration
when making investment decisions red
States from Texas to West Virginia have
pulled billions from BlackRock and other
money managers despite concerns that
doing so may hurt financially they also
launched investigations into the
influence of big money managers on
everything from reducing emissions
to racial Justice pretty pathetic what's
going on here but but here's what the
scientists did okay the sentence is like
I'm just not going to be playing this
card look like they give a score to
companies okay Tom why don't you talk
about what ESG is so the listener can
kind of get a better idea well there's
two things there's ESG and then there's
Dei and what Dei is a let's talk about
that first really quick Dei is a fair
measurement of of women minorities and
all the groups that are in your company
the more diversity means you're
reflecting the community and you've got
Fair hiring practices and everybody
comes on that's Dei ESG is different and
people get the two confused Dei is not a
bad thing it's a sign that companies are
doing things and many people have an
opportunity to work for you ESG is where
you are taking
political
unproven and positional elements and
you're pulling them into your company to
operate for them such as certain
environmental things and certain
governance things so when you take a
look at it you're going from Dei where
you're doing good things you can count
with all the wonderful people that
represents society as a whole they're a
part of your company to ESG that's kind
of I think and maybe and what it's
forcing people to do is make make
Oddball decisions that don't optimize it
I'll give you a simple example the
states operate 529 plans and people with
this little 500 can start putting into a
tax-free College savings account for
their kids many people millions and
millions of Americans have it you don't
have to have a million dollars to put
money in a 529 so it earns tax free so
there's something for your kids for
college but now the funds that are in
there that are governed by the States
they're following these ESG principles
and it is showing that it doesn't
optimize the return so people are going
to be losing out on things like 401ks
and on a 529 tax-free fund that you're
in Iowa you put 500 bucks in find a way
to put a couple hundred bucks a year see
if it grows and you have college fund
for your kid but instead the money
managers are put in handcuffs and
they're forced to make ESG investment
decisions and when they do that it's
de-optimizing the return it's a fact I'm
sorry you don't have enough
environmental investment well we don't
think that's prudent right now we're
looking at the market we're investing in
technology medicine these kinds of
things and we think that's all good that
energy sector looks good right now
consumer like uh you know blue jeans and
other things these companies look good
and we're making objective decisions
about what we're investing in the fundra
sorry where's your investment in um you
know in environmental carbon credit you
know Recruitment and it's like wait a
minute you know so you're forcing these
fund managers to do things that they
wouldn't normally do because a fund
manager is agnostic about one thing do
these particular sub funds and money
make money are they going to make money
because he wants to he or she want to
get a good grade for managing the fund
and ESG is forcing they're calling it
woke that's forcing money managers into
making decisions they wouldn't normally
make for your retirement your college
fund everything else sorry for the long
answer but this one this one grinds my
gears in a very big way it de-optimizes
what fund managers and money managers
are supposed to be doing for Americans
retirements and 529 plans and things
like that by the way like give you an
idea the highest who do you think what
company you think in America has the
icsg score
Apple alphabet number two yeah Google
number two Intel number three Microsoft
yeah number four Salesforce
number five Bank of America okay I mean
you look at the names Tesla has a low
ESG score they don't have a good ESG
score I don't know if you know what Elon
Musk called uh ESG he came out and flat
out just said yes she's a scam oh wow
yeah he flat I said yes she's a scam and
they're using it as a way to manipulate
shamat big critic of ESG and he believes
in climate change shimada's like I'm a
pro climate change guy I believe in
climate change but I believe he is she
is a scam so uh a musk tweeted ESG is a
scam it has been weaponized by phone
phony social justice Warriors they
target people like Elon Musk they target
people that are not willing to bend uh
yeah Exxon is a top rated as a top 10
best in the world for environment social
governance by s p five a while Tesla
didn't make the list think about this
Exxon Exxon is top 10 best in the world
for environment and Tesla well you know
what that means here's the manipulation
so Exxon can go out there and buy carbon
credits you get points for that they can
go out and uh do virtuous virtue
signaling by supporting you know you
know local charities that are active on
this but meanwhile they're a fossil fuel
you know manufacturer and processor so
you can game it if anyone has ever been
part of a company where you have a sales
plan and you get a commission to do this
and this and this and it's not just a
straight commission there's a couple
other incentives in it sales people will
game the plan won't they pat they'll try
to find ways to go around and optimize
what you're talking about I've never
worn them no no I don't mean you Pat but
I mean come on dude what do you mean you
people Thomas what do you mean
I get what you're saying I get what
you're saying no no it's anybody I'm
sorry you people when I meant that
anybody who's run a company or has run
consulting or has run things like the
Vault and everything that Pat runs you
know you run into companies who are
trying to run sales campaigns and do
good things for them sales guys and they
say my sales guys just find ways around
it and I said well you need to think it
over because the salesperson is going to
find the best way to manage it well
guess what big companies are doing that
with ESG virtue signaling and other kind
of fake investing to get their ESG
points so if they score on ESG and it
really had nothing to do did anything
really move the ball so I'm with you
when exxon's up there on that you're
like how are you scoring this and how
did they play the game and they got the
points for doing it maybe it's uh you
know a couple million to Bernie's
campaign there's another 200 ESG points
it's probably I bet you if you peel this
onion back it's uh some pretty nefarious
pretty fairest scoring system yeah so
anyways we'll see what's going to happen
much like kind of like the term woke
wasn't always a bad term like five years
ago when it sort of came into the
nomenclature it meant like all right you
kind of get what's going on and it's
kind of taken a life of its own these
days now if it's woke you're it's a bad
term I guess my question is when ESG
started
was it like all right it's sustainable
investing it's stakeholder capitalism
we're concerned about the environment we
are concerned about green energy we're
concerned about
um air pollution clean water you know
all these things you see these companies
BlackRock Apple Nvidia PayPal Verizon
Walmart Hilton like the list goes on and
on
so what changed meaning like it
initially it was a good idea all right
let's invest in companies that care
about communities or the Earth or
well-being much like how woke was like
let's address issues that plague society
and social societal issues but at some
point it's taking a turn for the worst
like what Elon has said is like all
right it's gone completely overboard
it's gone completely woke like at the
end of the day it does it just come down
to returns is that the problem is that
they're so concerned with so social
issues just think about what Elijah said
Exxon is top ten and Tesla's not on the
list so so when you think about Exxon
what give me I'm gonna give you a word
let's play Word game ready I'm gonna
give you a word you tell me one word
that comes to mind Michael Jordan
basketball go messy Neymar
Brazil Trump America Biden sleepy
Sanders
Communists Exxon oil Tesla electricity
green energy
like you realize like no I I don't know
if like
yeah no I get it so so so the same
people on the left that are saying we
should get away from oil give a top 10
to Exxon
and the company Tesla who has created
the movement of electric cars to get
away from using gas vehicles is not on
the list just because Exxon has publicly
said I'm gonna do good things please
forgive me and Tesla says yeah we're
doing good things I don't want to
publicize it but this is how we're doing
good things but Tesla gets a bad score
this is hypocrisy at its best and Elon
is absolutely right in this thing so so
do you understand the point I'm making
here completely and that's where I'm
asking where it went wrong meaning this
is where they went wrong right so so
it's kind of like this let me give you
an idea what it means
how was the you know the question about
how credit scores uh uh what do you call
it uh measured okay how is credit score
measure like FICO scores how's it
measured like hey you know Experian
Equifax TransUnion whatever okay imagine
you make all your payments on time
you make every single payment for your
house your rent your credit cards
everything's on time and you manage your
credit well okay but but you don't use
a credit card by Amex because Amex gives
XYZ amount of money to a climate change
organization because of that your credit
score went from a 780 to 620. now B of A
doesn't want to give you a loan to buy a
house this is the best explanation I can
give you for what this is the the method
of counting successful credit score
which is paying your [ __ ] on time has
been manipulated on who you're not
giving money to wow how the hell does
that make any sense it doesn't that's
the best way to explain ESG so with all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
our black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]